il est le tout nouveau secrétaire
général de l'Assemblée parlementaire de
la Francophonie l'APF Bruno Fuchs est
notre invité bonsoir bonsoir soyez le
bienvenus dans 64 minutes sur TV5 Monde
vous êtes député français un modèle du
Haut-Rhin membre de la majorité donc en
France et vous le savez avant de parler
de votre nouveau rôle à la PF forcément
le monde francophone regarde avec
attention les images qu'on a vu en début
de journal cette crise sociale et
politique qui dure en France comment
sortir selon vous en sortir qu'avec le
dialogue la discussion donc il faut
renouer le dialogue avec une grande
partie population qui ne veut pas de ce
texte qui ne connaît pas bien mais qui
n'en veut pas le message est clair on a
une proposition de Laurent Berger de la
CFDT de proposer une médiation il faut
que par tous les moyens on puisse
remettre les actes autour de la table et
regarder réellement comment on sort de
là et réellement quand on lira ce texte
quand on verra le contenu de ce texte on
verra qu'il y a pas mal de d'avancées
qui sont
le député les Français à le connaître
tout de même cette précision mais le
modem courant la famille à laquelle vous
appartenez pour cette médiation proposée
par Laurent Berger mais aussi la CGT de
Philippe Martinez mais le gouvernement
dit bah non non c'est pas c'est pas
obligé il y a pas quand même un jusqu'au
boutisme de la part du pouvoir je sais
que vous faites partie de cette majorité
mais tout de même ça commence à être moi
je pense que sur le fond on doit faire
une réforme des retraites tout le monde
le sait mais que sur la forme si la
forme avait été aussi bien faite que
cela on serait pas dans une crise avec
10 manifestations depuis le début donc
on a un problème de forme de méthode en
tout cas et aujourd'hui la seule façon
de s'en sortir c'est de discuter et la
proposition de leur berger est une bonne
proposition il faut refuser aucune
proposition on ne peut pas sortir si on
ne discute pas on a eu en France trois
grandes crises les gilets jaunes covid
et puis la crise du crâne qui concerne
tout le monde on peut pas avoir une
quatrième crise il faut calmer le jeu il
faut qu'on se mette autour de la table
une fois que on pourrait à nouveau se
parler je pense que on drague dans le
texte il y a pas mal d'éléments qui
pourraient plaire à beaucoup de
organisation syndicale voilà pour
certains passent donc qui dure depuis
près de trois mois on en vient votre
nouveau rôle de secrétaire général de
l'Assemblée parlementaire de la
Francophonie la francophonie ne séduit
plus redoublant d'efforts alors ça c'est
la tribune le titre de la tribune que
vous avez publié dès le lendemain de
votre élection c'était la semaine
dernière le vendredi pourquoi ne s'est
dit-elle plus la francophonie d'abord
elle attire encore un certain nombre
d'acteurs nous à l'APF on a fait on a
des nouveaux adhérents qui sont arrivés
le Monténégro le Kosovo on a de nouveau
adhérents qui veulent venir l'Angola le
Val d'Aoste l'Italie également donc
l'Ukraine on est la radar arrivé
effectivement au mois de juillet donc on
est on est organisations l'institution
attire mais la francophonie des peuples
des des citoyens attire moins d'abord il
y a une question qui est mécanique qui
est que dans un monde multilatéral et
bien d'autres acteurs qui arrivent donc
forcément votre influence est moindre
lorsque d'autres arrivent ça c'est tout
à fait naturel et puis ensuite parce que
je pense que on a du mal à se régénérer
c'est à dire à être attractif dans un
monde du 21e siècle la francophonie ne
pas aussi de la défiance qui existe
envers la France je veux dire notamment
une région qui vous intéresse le Sahel
par exemple alors ça c'est un troisième
facteur effectivement il y a l'image de
la France mais qu'à mon avis il n'est
pas structurant je pense que si la
France s'amende c'est une nouvelle
stratégie c'est les éléments qui dans la
durée dans ces quelques années peuvent
s'estomper la question la plus
importante pour le monde francophone
c'est de dire comme ça je peux la
formuler comment un jeune aujourd'hui
achnome Pen ou à Kinshasa en se levant
le matin à envie d'apprendre le français
a envie de se projeter dans un monde
francophone donc il faut réenchanter ce
monde francophone et aujourd'hui c'est
vrai qu'on parle beaucoup du passé on
parle beaucoup de l'histoire de la
culture de la langue on parle beaucoup
de la gouvernance la démocratie État de
droit
[Musique]
parlementaire de la Francophonie comme
le veut l'usage et la tradition quel va
être votre rôle concrètement et puis le
vice-président d'assemblée qui est le
président de l'Assemblée du Gabon
monsieur beaucoupby qui sera le prochain
président c'est tous les deux ans ça
tourne un nord africain un
nord-américain et en Afrique tous les
deux ans et le poste de général est
dédié à la France justement pour la
France soit pas en première ligne
justement c'est bien ça aussi le la
question alors moi mon rôle il va être
je vous l'ai dit c'est la question que
m'avait posée essayez de de perdre
trouver un corpus qui va essayer de
réenchanter et donc de rendre attractif
de créer une valeur ajoutée au monde
francophone on va le faire en faisant de
la diplomatie parlementaire pour les
parlementaires mais sur les grands
terrains d'opération pour essayer de
renouer de les liens avec son nombre de
pays qui quittent ou qui prennent de
leur distance vis-à-vis du monde
francophone on va essayer également de
faire un corpus législatif de prendre un
ou deux sujets par an législatif les
plastiques par exemple des chez
plastiques la régulation des plateformes
par exemple il y en a pas en Afrique et
c'est très dangereux pour la sécurité
publique voilà et donc on va essayer
ensuite de faire en sorte que section
par section chaque pays propose une loi
et vote une loi pour que dans mon
francophone il y ait une valeur ajoutée
une singularité propre à la Francophonie
Bruno Fox député français